[Music]
in the near future war rages across the
republic of gilead formerly the united
states of america and pollution has
rendered 99 of the female population
sterile the country under the rulership
of a totalitarian patriarchal theocracy
is designed in such a way that only
benefits the high class the lower class
members are separated from their
families and are forced into taking up
demeaning jobs there is little or no
justice and the country's citizens are
deprived of their fundamental right to
freedom the movie opens up with kate her
husband luke and daughter jill
attempting to cross over to canada from
the republic of gilead in an attempt to
escape the hardships of the country and
give their daughter a better life
unfortunately for the family of three
they are unable to reach their promised
land as the border patrol soon discovers
them after a horrendous encounter with
the border patrol officers that leaves
luke dead kate is taken into the system
while jill is nowhere to be found after
being arrested kate alongside some other
criminally convicted women is
transported to a holding facility where
they are tested when the results come in
kate and a handful of women receive
positive results they are immediately
separated from the others and are
transported to another location here
aunt lydia the woman in charge of the
red center an academy where handmaids
are trained meets them and explains that
they will all become handmaids she
further reveals to the women that they
were selected as handmaids primarily
because they're part of the republic of
gilead's one percent of fertile females
apparently pollution caused the majority
of the country's women to become sterile
exempting these lucky few after aunt
lydia's introductory speech the girls
are transported in a bus to the red
center on the bus kate meets moira and
the two become friends the next day aunt
lydia instructs the fertile women on
their duties as handmaids they are to
act as concubines to the wealthy but
barren couples of the country with the
primary purpose of bearing children for
them their duty is perceived to be an
act of service to god and to their
country and their training comes with a
good amount of scripted group chanting
and ritualistic violence to discipline
the girls not long after kate is taken
into the home of the commander aka fred
as his newest handmaid the commander's
wife serena joy welcomes kate into the
house but it's obvious she's displeased
by her presence serena immediately lays
down the rules for kate to adhere
strictly to she then proceeds to ask
kate if she wants to have a baby and the
latter says yes since that is her duty
as a child-bearing concubine serena
approves of this and tells kate they can
work together soon kate is indoctrinated
into the cult of handmaids and becomes
an official handmaid who walks the
streets in red garments after the
indoctrination ceremony she returns to
fred's house where serena shows her to
her room and gives her further
instructions kate then receives her new
name oh fred which means she belongs to
fred aka the commander aka mr
inferiority complex cause anyone who
insists on being called the commander
has issues that night she dreams of her
daughter jill the next day serena and
kate have a short rite with the
commander he and serena take turns
reciting a scripture from the old
testament and then pray that they would
be blessed to have a child through kate
at night kate and the commander have
their first ceremony with serena present
when kate wakes up the next day the
kitchen staff gives her instructions on
how she's to spend her day she's to wait
for a fellow handmaid named offglen
together the duo are to make a trip to
the grocery store to pick up supplies
for their respective houses later while
walking to and from the store kate and
offglen do some light talk on the
ongoings of the mayday war against a
resistance movement in the country they
also encounter a pregnant handmaid on
their way back who everyone applauds for
fulfilling god's duty as time passes it
becomes evident from kate's behavior
that she is unhappy with the turn her
life has taken one night kate is about
to steal a pair of scissors probably to
commit the unthinkable but she's soon
discovered by nick the commander's
chauffeur who has been giving her
flirtatious glances for a while he
doesn't report kate instead the both of
them make out passionately before nick
breaks the news to kate that the
commander needs her by 10 pm in his
office the next night when day breaks
kate asks of glenn what happened to the
last of fred since there have been two
other handmaids who served the commander
before her however of glenn claims that
she doesn't know anything about it
meanwhile the commander inquires to his
wife about what she thinks of their
latest handmaid to which serena replies
that she's better than the previous ones
that night nick escorts kate to the
commander's office thinking it's another
ceremony kate covers herself with her
veil however the commander locks his
door and tells her to remove it because
this meeting is not an official visit he
then reveals that he intends to get to
know kate better as a person because he
thinks if he gets closer to her she will
be more at ease and become a better
handmaid the commander suggests that he
and kate play scrabble which they do
after kate emerges as the winner of the
game the commander fires her ass because
no one beats the commander at scrabble
just kidding the commander offers her
some strawberries as a reward claiming
that he knew she would win the game
because she was a librarian he then
informs her that he will go to the
capitol for a week and while he is away
kate shouldn't forget him the next day
serena invites kate outside to assist
her with gardening she engages kate in a
discussion and tells her that the only
reason she gets handmaids is that she
wants a baby who would make her life
whole serena then lets kate know that
she's aware of the fact that kate has a
daughter when kate asks if serena knows
what happened to jill after she was
captured serena says she's equally
clueless and we'll try to find out three
months after kate's residence in the
commander's house she's still not
pregnant this makes the family anxious
and nick drives kate to a hospital to
run some tests meanwhile kate's doctor
tells her that there's absolutely
nothing wrong with her however he knows
the commander and suspects that he's the
one who's sterile because he has tried
twice before to have a child when kate
asks if they also test men for sterility
the doctor says they don't and that kate
will get the blame if it doesn't work
out surprisingly he offers to help kate
by impregnating her himself the doctor
says that no one will know it's not the
commander's child and that he has helped
many other women get pregnant this way
kate politely declines but he presses on
by warning her of the consequences if
she doesn't become pregnant when he
begins to make further advancements kate
threatens to scream for help and as a
result he finally lets her go back at
the commander's house kate is given one
more month to get pregnant or else
she'll be up for re-assessment in the
next scene the commander and kate play a
game of cards and kate is the winner
once again when she asks for her prize
the commander gives her a stash of
magazines that were supposed to be
burned because such material is illegal
meanwhile kate asks the commander to do
her a favor by giving her hand lotion
because she needs it for her dry skin at
first he obliges but after a while he
rethinks and mentions that his wife
might smell it on her and get furious
when kate argues that she's barely even
close enough to serena for her to notice
scent the commander agrees to give her
hand lotion on the condition that she
doesn't use it on the nights of their
ceremony during the next ceremony the
commander gets carried away and is about
to touch kate sensually however serena
immediately stops him fearing that he
might be more attracted to kate than her
later that night kate confronts the
commander and tells him to never try
touching her like that again because
serena will get angry and send her off
to the colonies where the standard of
living is unbearable kate then uses the
opportunity to ask what happened to the
last of fred the commander reveals that
she couldn't conceive so she committed
the unthinkable hearing this kate gets
taken aback and she quickly leaves the
office meanwhile serena is getting
impatient while waiting for kate to
conceive one day she calls kate over to
talk on the issue kate asks if she has
discovered anything about her daughter
but serena says she hasn't serena then
asks kate if she has had any pregnancy
signs and the latter says no as they
keep talking serena points out that
kate's time is running out she admits
that her husband might be infertile and
suggests that kate should sleep with
another man so she can become pregnant
kate reminds serena that she would be
killed for that but serena brushes it
off by saying women do it all the time
when kate asks her who she has in mind
serena tells her nick is a good fit for
the job because he's loyal to them
eventually kate agrees to the idea and
the two decide to keep it a secret that
night kate and nick get intimate and
this marks the start of their affair the
next day serena confesses to kate that
jill is alive apparently she had known
all along and was hoarding the
information from kate she then gives
kate a photograph of her daughter which
makes her emotional when she inquires
about jill's location serena merely
assures her that she's in good hands and
is well taken care of kate asks when she
can see her but serena breaks the sad
news to her that it's impossible because
jill wouldn't even recognize her as her
birth mother that night kate goes to
nick's room to confide in him she tells
him that she needs to see her daughter
nick knows her wish can't be granted so
he decides to comfort her instead while
she mourns some days later all the
handmaids watch the extraordinary event
of their fellow handmaid of walder
giving birth serena also witnesses the
event and becomes more impatient telling
kate to get pregnant soon meanwhile of
glenn advises kate to study the
commander and get to know everything
about him claiming that this would be
helpful the next time kate and the
commander meet at the commander's office
kate mentions that the commander is a
mystery to her and she would love to get
to know him better they then have small
talk and kate uses the opportunity to
study the commander and his thought
process some time later all the women
attend an event where they witnessed the
verdict of a handmaid who was found
guilty of seduction and fornication with
a medical staff member according to the
handmaid's training situations like
these are inevitably the woman's fault
and her punishment is death everyone
watches in delight as the other
handmaids pull the rope that eliminates
the handmaid in the public center next
another man is brought in and convicted
for the assault of a pregnant handmaid
all of the handmaids in the center are
furious and they eventually beat him to
death however kate and of glenn seem to
be the only sane women there and of
glenn reveals that she is a part of the
resistance she then tells kate that the
man wasn't guilty instead he was one of
their best men as they walk back to
their houses of glenn asks kate what the
commander wants from her since he sees
her privately of glenn then reveals that
the commander is the security chief
making him one of the resistance's
biggest targets almost immediately a
vehicle explodes behind the women and a
group of armed men starts shooting
sporadically the men are staff members
of the mayday resistance so they spare
all the handmaids in the area following
this of glenn tells kate that the
resistance may need her to kill the
commander as he has been their main
obstacle for a democratic state kate is
skeptical about the plan at first but
when she realizes that it's her only
chance to meet her daughter she agrees
later when kate returns to the
commander's office she is surprised when
he tells her he's taking her out and
gives her a fancy black dress and boa to
wear nick is their chauffeur and while
in the car kate has to lie down on the
floor during checkpoints because
according to the commander wives aren't
allowed where they're going when they
arrive at the destination which is
revealed to be an illegal nightclub the
commander introduces kate to everyone as
mary lou they both dance have drinks and
sleep together before eventually leaving
once they get back home kate goes to
nick's room and tells him that she's
pregnant for him and isn't going to give
up their baby to the commander and his
wife who she detests she then tells nick
that she wants to escape and asks him to
join her when kate returns to her room
to rest she finds on her dressing table
a note from of glenn saying 10 pm
tomorrow with a knife beside it the next
day kate goes to meet with of glenn to
tell her that she found the note but
when the girl turns kate realizes that
the of glenn she knew has been replaced
when she asks the unfamiliar woman where
of glenn is the lady claims to be of
glenn meanwhile serena finds out that
kate has been sleeping with her husband
outside the ceremonies she confronts
kate about it and insults her before
storming out of the house by 10 pm that
night kate prepares herself to eliminate
the commander when she enters his office
he's about to fire a gun at her but when
he sees it's kate he lowers his guard
kate then uses the opportunity to kill
him immediately nick and some other
police officers arrive at the house and
arrest her however the arrest is a ruse
because the police officers are actually
undercover mayday resistance who help
kate escape in the next scene nick and
kate have an emotional farewell because
nick has to return to join the mayday
resistance he tells kate that he'll keep
sending her messages and she should run
away and take care of their child until
he returns the episode ends with kate
hiding safely in the mountains thinking
about her first daughter jill while also
awaiting nick's baby's arrival subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching